[Music]
/ fear man must stand alone
Will Smith Ryan Reynolds Catherine
zeta-jones Dobie Joe Graham Norton's
pants rated on
[Applause]
okay this is very good - this is try
this try this one Jamie you got there's
any copies in the house yeah yeah you
could so but that shot - panda call
panted with fries okay depend quarter
panda there was a Nigerian comedian that
was talking about my performance in the
movie and he said he said Will Smith is
doing a Nigerian accent in his film and
the haters will say that it is no good
but I think that is not true I think he
sounds like a Nigerian with a concussion
you do your scare Pig I'll do we do
[Applause]
he was doing Chewbacca during the clip
what I'm with the two bucketing just
natural nature that's one of my favorite
back a moment sister
[Music]
[Applause]
that's I'm doing a Harrison Ford one-man
show in the West End theater references
Daisy you get to use your lovely English
voice okay
throughout okay John not so much no have
an American accent do it he's so good oh
it's a credit your accent is so big oh
thank you I mean I tried to end the
British by didn't work out I'm a
stormtrooper and they have say yeah
[Applause]
yo give me fun sea and Sun hot dog in a
bun just be quick drinkin spit
for actors you know you all have to do
accents but Ryan we don't think of
Canadians as having accents and yet
usually do
you've lost your accent you would say
yeah I sort of trained myself out of it
but you know I go back home and it pops
up again it's oh yeah it's a wild cat
it's a boat and that's not the way you
say do you talk about are you gonna boat
but it's all my everything is I it's a
bad word but I'm sorry so you handle
everything with ah [__] buddy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I will thank you Turia so I like I like
British accents because they're so sexy
[Applause]
talk to you later bye bye believers this
is gonna be beautiful
[Music]
here with the sand don't be discouraged
oh I realize it's hard to take courage
full of people you can lose sight of it
all and darkness inside you can make you
feel so small but I see your true
[Music]
courage it relays I'm beautiful
like a rainbow stay there I'm enjoying
this chance but he timed it right it's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
sometimes you picture me walk-in to
father hit you have said that you'll say
[Music]
Tom Cruise is doing you know Jerry
Maguire so they had the guy sees me read
and Elaine says I want you to go to read
440c in New York so who TC time for the
hawk Russo I go to read but as I'm
reading I'm loud show me the money
and so it's all good yeah white Tom
Cruise Reese his line but it was like
this so I thought he'd lost his place
here some we right he says I know I said
the line I'm waiting on you I'm like oh
we own the Graham Norton Show so we're
sitting here like a couple of regular
fellas I mean you do what you do I do
what I gotta do if I'm there and I gotta
put you away I won't like it but if it's
between you and some poor bastard whose
wife you're gonna turn into a widow
brother
you are going down Michael man cuts back
to the esteemed gentleman at the end of
the sofa what if you do gummi Buxton
I'm not gonna put you down we've been
face-to-face yeah but I will not
hesitate not for a second
that's my it's really embarrassing to do
in front of a whole room full of Brits
here but I'll try it anyways so it's
like mmm so I wanna say like a silly
scar
yes they did like like Michael cheat on
me was in a beef are telling me he's I
you know you know unless you or whatever
[Applause]
[Music]
I remember so distinctly that I started
to cream in my knickers I could